Blackwater was the most controversial  private Army in America it started out  as just a training facility for U.S  Special Forces but after 9 11 happened  the CIA approached them with an offer  they just couldn't refuse provide  security to high-level American  diplomats during the invasion of Iraq  Blackwater took the job on the spot  Blackwater had the best ex-special  forces soldiers working for them they  had their own helicopters they got into  a ton of insane firefights and most  importantly none of their clients died  on their watch but private military  contractors were very corrupt at the  time and when the government and media  needed a scapegoat to cancel they  brought the hammer down on Blackwater  and its founder Eric Prince which is why